♪♪
-I want to start
by addressing all of you
who recommended
I start using a coaster
when I have a drink at my desk.
I appreciate the advice.
[ Laughter ]
We showed a picture
of a stand-up flyer of mine,
and someone said,
"That is a bad flyer
because there is
no date, time, or place."
Well, I guess that explains
why it was so poorly attended.
[ Laughter ]
A cowboy's rope
is called a lariat.
Lasso is what you do with it.
"There's no faster way
to reveal yourself as a layman
to a cowboy
than by calling it a lasso."
The second-fastest way
to reveal yourself as a layman
is every time a male horse pees,
you say, "Oh, my God!"
[ Laughter ]
Once a pumpkin is carved,
it is no longer a pumpkin.
It's a Jack-o'-lantern.
Fine.
Um, an ornithologist wrote in.
[ Laughter ]
Said, "There's no such thing
as a seagull.
They're called herring gulls."
Hmm.
That's not what I'm "herring."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's plane is a 757,
not a 747.
However...
when Trump's doctor
gave the plane a physical,
he said it was a 215.
Topical.
I read the research.
We talked about the artist T.J.
who drew the photo
of Scollins in a tank top
and then wore it to the show
on a tank top.
And someone said he looks like
an unkempt Hunter Biden.
To which I'll say, since when
is Hunter Biden kempt?
[ Laughter ]
Had a joke about a Ford Escort.
Multiple people wrote in
to say the Ford Escort we showed
was the European Ford Escort
that was never available
in the States.
You all said it was
a better Ford Escort, but...
Did not work with our joke
about a county fair.
Long story short, we have
a foreign exchange student
in the graphics department.
[ Laughter ]
Not my favorite.
And I'll go down and be like,
"Hey, just in the future,
use the Ameri..."
He's like -- [French accent]
"But there was one, yeah?
There was also
a European Ford Escort.
It was better."
And I'm like,
"Francois, just..."
He's like, "Yeah,
well, maybe you could have
Sal choose a car that did not
have a European..."
"If you leave it up to me,
I'm gonna choose the best."
Very quiet.
[ Laughter ]
"Ohh..."
We made a joke about
Kyrgyzstan needing more vowels.
Someone wrote in and said,
"Kyrgyzstan has three vowels
and seven consonants,
which is pretty balanced.
The two Y's are both vowels."
I will respond
to this Kyrgyzstan correction
with a famous quote
from neighboring Kazakhstan.
[as Borat] "My wife."
[ Laughter ]
We said a 17-year-old
carnival worker --
A 17-year-old carnival worker.
A bunch of you said
this dude's not 17.
All I'll say is the
carnival life is unforgiving.
[ Laughter ]
You know how many times
this guy's watched
a kid barf up a funnel cake?
It'll age ya!
We talked about a county fair
and sort of one of those
dangerous roller coasters.
And I said in the wheel well,
rattling around
in the wheel well,
you saw an ankle bone.
Bunch of you said
there's no such thing
as a human ankle bone.
The ankle is a joint
made up of three bones --
the talus, the tibia,
and the fibula.
The thing is, there is a risk
of being too specific
when you tell a joke.
I think if you say,
you know, talus or tibia
instead of ankle bone,
I would worry that
I would be stealing moves
from Dennis Miller,
the sort of king of specificity.
I think he could
get away with that.
But I want to sort of fall back
on ankle bone. You know.
I don't want to be out there
being like...
[As Miller] "Bought a ticket
on the Jackrabbit."
"From a kid with deader eyes
than Boo Radley.
Looked down in the wheel well.
There's a talus
banging against the tibia
like the ball bearings
in Captain Queeg's hand."
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
That's his.
Doritos are not potato chips.
They are corn chips.
We talked about
throwing a Dorito
to a bunch of pigeons,
and that was incorrect.
If you throw a potato chip to
a bunch of pigeons on a beach,
as we established
in the "Closer Look,"
they would be like,
"Mah-mah-mah-mah!"
If it's a corn chip,
they're like, "Mah-mah--
Mah! Mah! Mah!"
Tampa has a great airport.
Kind of joked down Tampa,
but I was in their airport
this summer.
It's an outstanding airport.
And the only thing I'd say
to the people of Tampa is, like,
sometimes I just have to
sort of throw chum
to the liberal elites
that watch this show, you know?
[ Laughter ]
I want to be a talk-show host
for all America.
It's tough.
Oh, we said there was a Subway
sandwich called "The Rudy"
that was two pieces of bread --
All it was
was two pieces of bread
and a bunch of [bleep] nuts.
But old Graphics was like,
"And lettuce!"
[ Laughter ]
"We thought the lettuce
was implied.
Why? Did you hear
from a hundred ass [bleep]?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, someone said, "There are
peanuts and cashews in there.
Those aren't nuts."
[ Sighs ]
[ Chuckles ]
Peanuts and cashews aren't nuts!
Ankles aren't bones!
There's no such thing
as seagulls!
It's fun doing a show for you!
It's fun!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we talked about Trump
wearing Hannibal Lecter's mask
to stop him from speaking.
Hannibal Lecter's mask
did not stop him from speaking.
There's a whole scene
where he talks through it.
It stopped him from biting.
It's so --
That movie is so good.
I love that movie.
The movie is terrifying.
Wonderfully acted,
written, directed.
It's so funny looking back
that the main thing the villain
did was bite people.
Like, to the degree --
Because anybody can bite.
But his biting was so good,
they had to take extra steps
to prevent him from biting.
And even after they did that,
he still got a lot of bites in.
Like, he's strapped down
like this,
and they still were like,
"Let's put a thing here."
All you'd have to say is, like,
"Just don't get in
the bite zone."
[ Laughter ]
And someone was like, "I think
we just put the mask on."
They were like,
"How good is he at biting?"
They're like, "He's so good."
So many steps so that
he wouldn't bite anybody,
and everybody gets bitten!
I feel like
if you were a prison guard
who got bit
by Hannibal Lecter,
you just want him to
finish the job and eat you up.
Because you'd be --
If the other prison guards
saw it,
you would get so much grief.
They'd be like,
"Hey, Joe, uh, can't help
but notice you got bite marks
on your cheek there."
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got bit."
[ Laughter ]
"Who was it, Joe?
Uh, which one of the prisoners?"
"You [bleep] know who it was!"
[ Laughter ]
Um...
I keep saying "uh-SIGH" berry.
It's pronounced "uh-suh-ee."
And to that, I say ugh.
Or better yet -- ug-guh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
Let's see. Uh, McDonald's.
We made a joke about
how McDonald's
shut down their ball pits
because they kept finding
dead bodies in them.
There is still one active
ball pit in America.
It's in Marlborough, Mass.
So apologies.
I guess people still go
into that ball pit every day.
But here's a cool fact.
No one leaves.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Sometimes you get
the camera shot just right,
and it doesn't pay off.
[ Laughter ]
We said this is the sound
of Wile E. Coyote
falling off a cliff,
and we replaced it with
a gavel hitting the "lectern."
And...
[ Laughter ]
But someone said,
that's not the sound
of him falling off a cliff.
It's the sound of him
hitting the ground.
And also when the coyote
hits the ground,
you wouldn't hear the sound
right away.
You'd hear it
like two seconds later
as the sound traveled back up.
So we redid it.
Here is the sound
of Wile E. Coyote
hitting the ground.
[ Whistle! ]
-[Bleep] off!
[ Laughter ]
We busted Wally
in yesterday's "Closer Look"
for having --
He had a line
in Monday's "Closer Look."
The line was, "Well, Seth..."
And he thought
it was short enough
that he wouldn't need
one of his other guys
to hold his cue cards.
And then we saw in the edit
that he had something
written on his hand,
and we zoomed in,
it said, "Well, Seth."
So, obviously --
And Wally's since explained it.
He just -- You know, he had some
other cues he wanted to make.
He's a professional.
And I didn't want to
call attention to it.
It was Sal.
It's so weird because no one
is more pro-labor than Sal.
I mean, Sal is the most
pro-labor person I've ever met.
Sal wrote an incredible piece
in "The New Republic"
about the writers strike.
It's really a beautiful --
no surprise --
piece of writing from Sal.
He's got this weird blind spot
about cue-card guys, though.
He just, like --
He treats them bad.
Behind his back,
they all call him Boss Genteel.
And he's always telling us,
"We should do the show
without him."
And I'm like, "We can't do
the show without him."
He's like, "We could
if you'd memorize your lines!"
"They're my words!
Don't you see?!
They're just moving them
from one place to the other!
But, oh, they're the heroes!"
It's very ugly.
He's so mean to Wally.
Wally will be like,
"How was your weekend, Sal?"
He's like,
"Oh, it was wonderful, Wally.
I went to the teleprompter shop!
Brought my wife and my mistress!
I said, 'Ladies,
you can each pick one out!'"
"Your days are numbered, Wally!
Oh, I can see it now!
'Here lies Cue Card Wally.
Cause of death --
march of time.'"
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned the chemical
in thermal receipts.
I was told
it should be pronounced
the way you say "biscuit."
So I said "bye-sphenol."
But I should have said
"biscuit."
[ Laughter ]
I said I didn't know
football games had ushers
because I get taken straight
to a luxury box.
Someone said,
"Who takes you if not an usher?"
Well, my personal manservant.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna let a stranger
take me to a box.
Kidnapped much?
[ Laughter ]
Here's a question.
We've dealt with this before.
Is the Speaker of the House
second in line
to the presidency
or are they third in line?
It goes
President, Vice President,
Speaker of the House.
We want to clarify.
We looked.
So, we actually looked
in the Constitution,
and it says there --
and I quote --
"It's whatever one
you want it to be."
[ Laughter ]
Here's a comment we got
this week.
This is in the comments section.
Someone decided, "Oh."
Watching it, and they're like,
"Oh, I'll make sure
I write this down.
Want to make sure they see it."
"What the [bleep]
is this boring, stupid show?"
[ Laughter ]
That's a good question.
Here's one for you.
Why the [bleep]
are you watching it?
Like, what are you doing?
Like, we all know what this is.
Alright?
The Jackals know what it is.
I know what it is.
We like this little thing
we have.
You don't got to watch it, man.
Why did the YouTube algorithm
even show it to you?
Did you watch another video
where a guy made, like, dog toys
with human heads hump?
You got to walk in and be like,
"What the [bleep]?"
You're like somebody
who goes to a Renaissance fair
and you're like, "Do you guys
not know what year it is?!"
"We're having fun, dude!
Eat your turkey leg
and drink your [bleep] mead
out of a Solo cup
or get the [bleep] out of here!"
[Bleep]
"Doth that make sense?"
[ Laughter ]
"What the [bleep] is this?"
We had a --
We had a joke a woman --
The story was that
a woman in Australia
is recovering after she tried
to rescue a platypus
with her bare hands
and was stabbed...
with its poisonous spurs.
It's not poison. It's venom.
Venom is injected.
Poison is ingested.
Now we know.
Then I went off script...
which I'm allowed to do.
And I mimed
'cause I know a little --
I know one or two things
about platypuses,
that they also lay eggs,
so I mimed it laying an egg.
So it turns out a lot of you
know like 300 to 400 things
about platypuses...
and said, "Only the male
has the venom-delivering spur,
so it couldn't lay an egg."
So many of you said that.
I'm assuming
all Australian viewers.
So I'd just like to say...
[Australian accent]
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I apologize.
I feel as though I've done you
a grave injustice.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Oh.
This has been "Animal Flubs."
-♪ Animal Flubs, Animal Flubs ♪
♪ It's time to take a look
at some Animal Flubs ♪
♪ From the birds to the bees
to the baby bear cubs ♪
♪ It's time for Animal ♪
-♪ What am I? ♪
♪ How am I even a thing? ♪
♪ It's so weird I exist ♪
♪ Do I serve any purpose? ♪
♪ Do you know
how most platypuses die? ♪
♪ It's when
they first see a mirror ♪
♪ And they're so bummed out ♪
♪ That they eat
their own venom ♪
♪ At which point ♪
♪ The venom becomes poison ♪
♪ Because it's ingested ♪
Back to you, Koala.
-The [bleep] was that?
-What the [bleep]
is this boring, stupid show?
[ Laughter ]
Stevie Nicks
doesn't wear scarves.
She wears shawls.
So at least we finally
got to the bottom
of why those jokes
haven't been landing.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people said the real
Scarf King would be --
Here were some of the choices.
Lenny Kravitz.
Little Steven
from the E Street Band.
Steven Tyler
got the most answers.
Uh, true story --
Steven Tyler's dad
was Shoemaker's music teacher
in high school.
And if you don't think
Shoemaker brings that up
every time
an Aerosmith song plays...
dream on.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see.
[ Muttering ]
[ Laughter ]
Steven next week.